But wait.
What happens to the files that were
previously stored in the cache after
installing a new one?
The browser doesn't know whether you're
going to need the old ones or not.
So it's up to you to clean
the unused files from the cache.
The activate event is
the perfect place to do this.
When the activate event is fired,
the code gets a list
of current cache keys and iterates
through them using the map function.
It then compares the key to the current
key and if they're not equal,
purges them.
This method does have a few
disadvantages though.
First, this caching method,
requires us to update the cache key
every time one of the App Shell
resources is changed.
Otherwise, the old
content will be served.
So be sure to update your
cache key with every change
as you're working on your project.
Another downside is the entire
cache is invalidated and
needs to be downloaded every
time a single file changes.
This means fixing a single spelling
mistake will invalidate the cache and
require everything to
be downloaded again.
Not exactly efficient.